do you love her she's one of them like
me special patient thank you
pat croak has endured her long wait for
an operation with unbelievable stoicism
despite being in agony how long have you
been waiting for your knee replacement
i'd say about three years
but then you know the carving
but
it's sort of you have to wait don't you
everybody's waiting
and what was it like what was the pain
like for the three years you were
waiting oh absolutely atrocious
two weeks ago she finally had her
surgery it's a massive relief
all this time she's barely left her home
practically unable to walk
i had so many falls
all around this side here there was no
skin at all that scraped it all off
[Music]
pat is recovering at holton hospital in
cheshire
they are covered free thanks to testing
some hospitals have stopped screening if
you don't have symptoms across the nhs
they're having to make difficult choices
between protecting the vulnerable and
providing desperately needed care
there's a patient that spoke to spoken
to recently
whose her operation was cancelled five
times and three times of that were
because of covid you have to think about
how that limits people's lives you could
be waiting years for operations it's
increased pain
you know their quality of life
you know just deteriorates
the government and nhs england want no
one to be waiting more than two years
for treatment by july
look at today's figures and that seems
like an ambitious target
one of the biggest challenges facing
this trust like many others is coming
from a e people who put off seeing a
doctor during the pandemic now really
sick people who can't get a gp
appointment they're all showing up at
the emergency department and they need
specialists delaying care for other
patients
and to make things worse
figures of staff sickness have probably
over doubled in the last few few weeks
and months probably as high as they've
been throughout the pandemic other than
wave one
and we're doing that at the same time as
opening up more and more escalation beds
to cope with the demand so that is a
real really difficult real challenge for
us
chronic pain and the pandemic isolated
pat from her great-grandchildren
lovely to see them all again
not all at the same time
she's happy to wait just a little longer
to get her strength back becky cottrell
sky news cheshire